hello mysterious text teases your
curiosity you're in a darkroom let's say
an amuse in basement no even better
somewhere more adventurous a cave yeah
your excitement fades to baffled wonder
as your brain starts to hum with the
tedium of cracking this text a tedium
that calls not for the brazen
adventuring of an Indiana Jones but the
careful testing of a Turing or shampoo
yawn you don't know the language of this
text you don't even know what words it
encodes you can't even start to
pronounce its symbols you're not even
sure this is writing at this moment of
confusion if your ear is free fellow
language traveler and budding decipher
let me hold out my hand and offer a
morsel of hope what if I told you that
you can know what these symbols are
without ever needing to know how to read
them and what if I also told you all you
needed to do this was to know how to
count
first pluck out the basic writing types
you met in thought spill what you
haven't seen that no way come on let's
go watch it first and then come back and
pluck out the basic writing types you
met in the Spill consonant vowel symbols
syllable symbols and word symbols now
let's start counting take a string in
English just a bit of written text and
count the number of distinct graphing
you find in it okay but longer is better
here more chances for all the signs in
the writing system to show up including
those less common ones you know your cue
your X's your Z's so let's count the
signs in all of Shakespeare's sonnets
I'm counting everything but X so keep
taking more and more bigger and bigger
samples in English and you'll end up
counting the 26 letters of our alphabet
do the same for Russian and I hear you
count 33 try it with Hawaiian and you
only find 13 now reach for Japanese text
written entirely in syllables you'll
count 46 hiragana Cherokee has 85
syllables well now here's a jump up to
Hittite with over 500 symbols Maya with
more than 800 and Chinese with thousands
upon thousands so we end up with
alphabets on one end syllabaries in the
middle and logo graphic or logo phonetic
scripts on the far side but now you're
facing a new script totally unknown to
you and you count the symbols it has
hundreds what kind of script do you
think it is what if it has 20 what if it
has 50 or 60 we're using this simple
algorithm to make an educated guess
about an unknown script
this thing's reference conceptually in
papers about decipherment but I don't
know what it's called
Robinson points us back to Archibald
Sayce a man who loved himself some
Assyrian so do we call the safes test
the Archibald heuristic pulling a seis
yeah pulling a safes pulling a seis does
come with challenges and drawbacks too
first there's the problem that you still
can't read the text true but before you
take all of the wind out of my sails
please celebrate with this handy tool
can do for you
second scripts can emphasize things but
they're not really purely phonetic or
pure logographs I mean think of the mix
of letters numbers punctuation and even
ideographs you find all around you and
that's just in English perhaps the
biggest problem is how to identify
distinct symbols if you are trying to
decipher the Latin alphabet could you
tell that all of these are the same
symbol how what about capital letters
and lowercase letters are accent marks
distinct letters how do we count
ligatures linked scripted together
mashed together characters or the
component consonant vowel pieces of a
single index syllable or the sound plus
meaning pieces inside of a single
Chinese character we have explanations
for these and maybe they're good enough
for the scripts we already know but what
about trying to read an undeciphered
script or mo are these strange people
looking things too flipped variants of a
single sign are they two different signs
true i admit it this little algorithm
doesn't pull us out of the dark but it
gives us a starting point we can
identify script types we can list
symbols we can then use these lists to
identify the symbols when they show up
in other texts with a smile on our face
because even though this script is still
unknown to us we've devised a clever way
to reach a strange familiarity with it a
big step on our way to decipher MIT
I took a little time to play around with
and put together some simple code that
runs this test on any piece of text you
give it it counts the number of
different symbols that are in that text
then uses those cutoff numbers from
earlier to guess what kind of writing
system this is so let's try it for
English the English alphabet here's the
26 English letters will pass it down
through here and run this thing it tells
us that English is an alphabet who'd
have thought same thing but with some
random sentences still in alphabet let's
go for hiragana down here run it and
it's syllables what about Hawaiian if
you two have ever shared the misfortune
of leaving Hawaii you may have heard
this and it's in an alphabet and then
there's kanji oh yes whole list of them
and their word symbols well that's super
nerdy but thanks for letting me play
with language of it here it's kind of
nice doing more off-the-cuff video like
this that's a thing right off the cuff
it sounded wrong for some reason well
leave comments and subscribe and
encouraged me to come back again okay
bye